few days away from the big premiere how
are you feeling right now
anxious anxious just because I want
everyone to see it I'm excited it's been
so long the release was supposed to be
months ago and you know we pushed just
to have more time for everything to get
everything the way we wanted it for
everybody and I think over these last
couple months it's just been more
anxiety so I've been like oh my god I
just want everyone to see it already I
just want everyone to get to know me I
feel like you know people don't that
haven't really got to know me my whole
life so I'm really excited for that what
is gonna surprise us the most about you
probably how much I work I don't think
yeah because everything I've done this
year is yet to come out and you get to
you know there's a you get to go see me
interns go shoot a movie in Atlanta so
like there's a lot that I've been
working on this year that was actually
showcased on the show so I'm really
excited for that I feel like a lot of
people don't know that you're sober so
what was it like going through this
journey and managing and maintaining
your sobriety I mean look at the end of
the day it's just all about what my
priorities are I love my work I like
being healthy I like being happy I like
not ruining relationships in my life I
don't know it's it's something it was a
choice of mine because I just wanted to
really I wanted to work hard and I
didn't want to ruin anything and I've
seen so many people in my position
especially young people have everything
take it from them because of that so you
know I just want to be an example maybe
for young people that you know you know
drugs and alcohol using the wrong way
can really your life up I talked to
Jason about that too and he said you
guys had some nice conversations while
filming how is that to have him almost
as like a support in a way yeah I mean
it's crazy because I've been sober
longer than Jason have you really yeah
so it's just it doesn't change the
dynamic but it's always funny to meet
somebody that's a lot older than you
that you have more I don't know in a way
you know he learns for me I learn from
him it's a really it's a really good
process it's always nice to have someone
around that's not up all the time like a
lot of the people on the cast so yeah
I only imagine the type of drama that
goes on we've had a few tequila nights
with Frankie where I'm just sitting
there like get me out of here
I know people are asking you about your
parents we saw your mom in the trailer
it's been a year though since you and
your dad really made headlines it sounds
like you guys are in a great place
though you've said you're in a good
place how much of that relationship will
we see this season I mean that's
something I've tried to keep private
between me and my dad but there's it's
definitely you know it's inevitable that
that spills over onto my show and it was
a big part of my life it was something
that was really prevalent in my life at
the time and during most of the filming
process so I think you get to see a
little bit of that and it's definitely a
hard time for both of us how is he gonna
feel watching it back I don't know I
feel like I was pretty angry when we
were filming so I don't remember what I
said which is like kind of
nerve-wracking to Bob I try to tell me
I'm like dude I don't know if I said
anything crazy but who knows you know I
was really upset when all that stuff was
going on but you know you know friends
fight he's one of my best he's like my
best friend so people get over it did
you sort of sit your parents down and
say okay so here's what I think might be
happening here's what I don't know is
gonna happen
no because I have no idea what's gonna
happen and I haven't told anybody I'm
like listen it could just be whatever I
have no I have no idea have no control
you know people added things certain
ways and whatever is it most interesting
will make it that's for sure so I
assured them both it'll be interesting
your personal life I heard maybe
something happens with Miss Stephanie
Pratt oh did she tell you that no I
don't know it's complicated it's really
complicated but you know there's you
know that was one of the hardest things
for me is trying to put my personal life
on the show and it was hard at first but
you know more than I expected definitely
happened with that and I think you guys
will get to see some relationships on
the show and see kind of how I am with
that and how that plays out ultimately
are you single right now I am single so
you can tell how that played out so you
know what you'll see it's an it's
interesting never a dull moment in the
hill
don't miss the premiere of the hills new
beginning Monday June 24th attend on MTV